we're going to talk about meteorology
so you know as pilots we're just trying
to understand the basics and in terms of
passing the exam you know you don't need
to be a physicist you just mostly are
trying to learn stuff that will help you
fly within the VFR weather minimums and
predict when those minimums aren't
likely to be met or when there's going
to be really serious hazards such as
thunderstorms all right this will be on
the test you have to memorize all of
this well you kind of do anyway they
want you you will have to learn some of
the stuff for the exam in reality around
here
almost all airspace is at least class
echo that's controlled airspace it means
controllers could give you a clearance
to fly on instruments and separate you
from other aircraft so they want you to
be well separated from clouds a thousand
feet above 500 feet underneath 2,000
horizontally that way if any aircraft
under IFR comes out of the clouds
there'll be some time for the two of you
to see and avoid each other you can see
the weather minimums are different in
class golf airspace and actually in
uncontrolled airspace like up in Alaska
if you're flying on instruments you
don't have a clearance so say well how
is that possible you can be instrument
rated have an instrument capable
airplane and fly from airport to airport
in the clouds but the air traffic
controllers they can't give you a
clearance and guarantee you separation
from other aircraft because they don't
have radar they don't even have the
authority it's not controlled airspace
I've done some flying up there and
little airplanes and you have to be very
patient another interesting thing to
notice about this we'll talk about it
more again later is notice how class
bravo airspace has lower minimums an
ordinary class echo airspace so we have
to be a thousand feet from the clouds
here here we just have to be clear
the clouds wide why are there weather
why are the minimums reduced
right around Logan Airport and JFK and
LAX and they are yeah a great answer so
her answer is that air traffic control
is in contact with everybody in cost
bravo airspace and knows where they are
and act in fact they're on clearances in
class bravo airspace so they're being
told what to do fly this heading fly
that heading maintain this altitude
great answer all right so how do we know
if the weather minimums are going to be
maintained let's talk about weather
theory so raise your hand if you're a
science major here as opposed to
engineering
where are the smart scientists all right
Francis so the science approach to this
task would be to say you know if we
could just assume that humans are only
four inches tall then we could build
some really great aircraft and we'll get
into that in a moment just think about
that if you're a scientist how much
flexibility can you have compared to
being an engineer all right so let's
look at the atmosphere that we do have
mostly the troposphere tops out around
40,000 feet according to this chart and
that's where most of the vapor water
vapor is and therefore most of the
weather also the higher temperatures you
can see it actually does get warm again
way up high in the thermosphere this is
in kilometers on the left so you can see
that the part of the earth that we're
flying through is really just I don't
know probably around 20 kilometers and
down I would he let her glass a said he
could go up to 65,000 feet in this f-22
so that's what about
that's a little over 10 miles so I could
yeah it's about 20 kilometers somewhere
in that neighborhood anyway so not too
many people are going higher than just
the bottom 0 through 20 on this chart
alright who's concerned about global
inequality raise your hand
awesome well you'll be pleased to know
that so is the FAA and this figure here
shows you why it's warmer at the equator
and up at the North Pole there's the
same amount we're missing a little bit
of tilt here but that's ok
there's the same amount of incoming
solar radiation but it gets spread out
over a larger portion of the earth up
near the poles all right so this is
where guys like Francis have it easy if
you want to understand something you
just say well you know I've got an earth
and it's pretty much the same as the
existing earth it just doesn't have any
water on it and it doesn't rotate and
it's not tilted with respect to the Sun
so now I'll do my analysis and I'll
publish my paper and I'll get tenure and
your problem is solved so let's say
let's see what would happen here in a
non-rotating non tilted waterless earth
it would get hotter at the equator and
the air would rise up from the heat so
we can see that here so we would have
low pressure right there at the equator
and then the air would circulate up and
we would have high pressure up at the
poles that makes sense to everybody
all right great problem solve it can go
home unfortunately as engineers we have
to deal with the real world a little bit
more so if we're spinning around the
earth we're going to end up with these
three cells and in each hemisphere
and in this case you end up still with
the low pressure at the equator but then
you get a high pressure with all the air
sinking down here and you get still low
pressure
you still get high pressure up at the
poles and low pressure down here see if
I got that right
high it should be high it's high
pressure 13 degrees north oh yeah hi hi
that's good and yes and low and low all
right we got that right
it gets more confusing as you see okay
so the circulation one thing that the
FAA wants you to know is that it's a
it's heat exchange that drives the
weather so the weather is basically a
function of the Sun heating up the earth
and then it's not uniform so the heat
gets pushed from one part of the earth
to another and all this unequal heating
is responsible for you know the
altimeter varying for wind blowing
around pretty much every phenomenon that
is of interest to pilots is caused by
heat trying to move from the hotter
parts of the earth to the colder parts
of the earth
we'll talk about a little bit more about
these but notice there's parts of the
earth that are windier than others
unfortunately we're in one of the
windier parts okay so you also have to
know as a pilot just what an isobar is
that's the line of equal pressure and
that tells you that gives you an idea of
how the wind is going to move we'll see
that in a minute
the tighter the isobars the more
dramatic the pressure change in a region
and it's the pressure gradient force
that's causing the wind to flow from the
high to the low pressure so you might
think
on this chart for example that wind
wherever you see an L and an H that you
would just draw a vector of wind from
one place to the other right that kind
of makes sense however there is Coriolis
force this is for Francis the science
major Francis what course are you
[Music]
alright so scientists wear lab coats
Coriolis force is a fake news force
formerly known as fictitious so you can
see they're throwing the ball straight
but because they're on a rotating
platform it's apparently curving so
camera is mounted to the ground and will
see the ball going straight they're
gonna draw you a little dashed line at
one point so you can see the path is
actually straight
so the ball has inertia basically once
it's launched it wants to keep doing
whatever it was doing and this guy's
white lab coat colleague just moves away
from where the ball was going
[Music]
all right everybody's got that that's
Coriolis force for you
what happens when we do this on the
earth so think about it you have a
parcel of air that's moving with the
earth at the equator if you displace it
up to a higher latitude it still has
that velocity but now the earth isn't
spinning as fast so it ends up
essentially moving a little bit to the
right that is the fundamental insight
just as you saw in that video I'll have
to go home and think about that a little
bit but basically I think the most
effective way to think about it it's
just that the parcel of air that was at
the equator wants to keep moving as if
it were still at the equator but it's
not there anymore so it moves relative
to the underlying earth if you combine
the Coriolis force and the pressure
gradient then you get the actual wind
direction and the trend has seen here
eventually there's so much Coriolis
force over so much time that the wind
actually moves exactly 90 degrees to
where you think it should move it it
flows along the isobars instead of
perpendicular across them so there you
have a couple pressure systems and you
see that the wind is circulating around
these lows and highs rather than flowing
directly from one to the other as you'd
expect all right
[Music]
who would like to be calm a helicopter
test pilot raise your hand if that
sounds like a fun job okay so when
you're developing the manual for your
Sikorsky helicopter you've got to go
somewhere where the wind is calm where
would you all just going now that you've
seen this chart
who wants what's your name sir sorry
Jeremy where do you want to go you're
gonna take your Sikorsky helicopter and
you're gonna write the poh Florida
Sikorsky which is headquartered in
Connecticut they have a big flight test
facility I believe it's in Palm Beach so
there you have it they they thought just
along the same lines as you and they'll
be in the horse latitudes there's a
whole bunch of there nobody really knows
why it's called the horse latitudes one
idea is that the ships and since there's
no wind in those latitudes they have to
find a current and then they get pulled
along by the current as if they were on
a horse all right surface friction is a
little bit complicated it tends to drag
down the wind you'll have to study this
vector diagram on your own but really
for the from the FAA is point of view
they just want you to know mostly that
the wind you know two or three thousand
feet up is going to be different from
the wind on the surface because of
surface friction it'll be less intense
and in a slightly different direction
okay vertical circulation of the air I
think you're going to be okay if you
just remember that warmer air is lighter
than colder air
that's all you that you pretty much need
to know okay local wind patterns if you
heat up the shoreline the air will rise
off the shore and pull in air from the
ocean during the daytime so you got that
sea breeze and then at nighttime the
opposite happens so you get a land
breeze so there are some of these
predictable local weather patterns
the bigger ones have to do with
atmospheric stability if you have a
stable atmosphere meaning that a
displaced parcel there tends to get
pushed back down to wherever it was then
you get these weather characteristics
where you're not going to be bumped
around in your aircraft you're going to
have trouble seeing and you're gonna see
clouds that are basically flat these
stratiform clouds here that you see on
the right if it rains it's just gonna
rain all day it's gonna be a typical
miserable New England day where it rains
all the time or Seattle I guess it's
like that as well well what about if the
air once this place tends to want to
keep being displaced if it rises up a
little bit it keeps rising then you have
these clouds with vertical development
and the good news is you can see really
well you're not going to have an
obstruction to visibility unless you're
you know in heavy rain and the rain
won't be all day every day
it'll be showering but it'll be very
turbulent if you get into that cloud or
maybe right underneath that cloud okay
what about the profile of the atmosphere
let's have a look at this so on the
right I wonder if this is actually my
newest version of the presentation we'll
say I corrected an error on the right
you can see that for every thousand feet
you go up so we'll go from 0 to 1,000
feet up the temperatures gone from 18
Celsius to 15 so it's laps by 3 degrees
and the dew point has gone down by half
a degree does that make sense the air
goes up it's lower pressure
this is called an adiabatic process I
was not a chemistry major but I think
that means that you know we're not
adding or taking away
heat from the air we're just moving it
so the temperature and dew point spread
actually does get narrower you can see
as we rise up to 5,000 feet and the
spread has gone down to two and a half
degrees because the dew point is not
following nearly as fast as the overall
temperature does that make sense so I
think this is conceivably could be an
FAA test question that the dry adiabatic
lapse rate is three degrees okay then
the moist air is lapsing only at two
degrees so this figure shows you going
from zero to a thousand feet and from
one to two thousand feet we were
dropping three degrees per thousand feet
after that we're dropping only two
degrees per thousand feet and once the
temperature dew point spread goes to
zero that's when the cloud happens so
the air can't hold any more water vapor
and when the temperature and dew point
meet the water turns into the water
vapor turns into water and I've got a
cloud all right so you might ask
yourself well why if this why is this
air moving at all why does it start
moving one thing that can start it
moving is a mountain range so the air
gets pushed by a wind coming from the
left side of the slide up to the top of
the mountain and at that point it will
condense into a cloud just let you
absorb that cloud here for a minute
notice also that relative humidity is
just another way of stating the
temperature dew points spread so here
temperature and dew point are pretty
close 10 and 15 or 15 and 10 so we got
relative humidity of 80 percent over
here they're quite far apart the
temperature is 23 and the dew points
minus 2 so the relative humidity is low
okay you've heard that you know there's
a cold front coming in and we have all
these thunderstorms oh this is why the
cold air is denser than the warm air so
it pushes the warm air up and at that
point you get clouds forming and you get
thunderstorms all along the line of the
cold front okay so what if you have
stable air let's have a look at this you
end up let's see we've we've gone from
zero to one to two and we've only
dropped
[Music]
we've only dropped
we're only dropping actually we're not
even we're not dropping at all and then
we're back up this is an inversion okay
so basically the air temperature is
pretty constant as we go up so if a
parcel of air rises up into the
atmosphere it's not warmer than the
surrounding it's not going to be warmer
than the surrounding air so doesn't want
to keep rising okay what if it's
unstable so look at this by contrast the
environmental air temperature is lapsing
at a higher than standard rate so it's
going up it's going down four degrees
Celsius per thousand feet and this
parcel of air that was in equilibrium
down at sea level is still warmer than
the surrounding air and therefore it
wants to keep rising does that make
sense so basically if it if it goes up
and it wants to keep going up that's
unstable in a perfect situation for
forming thunderstorms which we'll talk
about shortly temperature inversion like
we saw in that earlier slide
where it was actually a little bit
warmer here that tends to keep air where
it is and therefore you end up with poor
visibility and haze because all the
stuff that's obscuring your visibility
is just staying underneath the inversion
it's kind of a common phenomenon I think
in some of these basins like Los Angeles
talk about an inversion and you know
ordinary people think about that and
hear that term and worry about it most
frequently you're gonna I think see this
on the test maybe is a radiation thought
you know rady phenomenons phenomena
having to do with the ground radiating
back heat into the atmosphere or into
space at night and to make the ground
cold and the air right next to the
ground cold where's the air just
slightly higher than that a couple
thousand feet up hasn't changed his
temperature too much so the terrestrial
radiation on a clear still night can
cause a temperature inversion we talked
about this earlier when the temperature
and dew point meet then that's when the
water vapor will condense Frost when the
dew point is below freezing and you have
a surface that's cold then you will get
maybe maybe it's called because it
radiated its heat back out into space at
night for example that's when you get
frost forming and you want to definitely
clear that off your aircraft before you
go anywhere because it messes with the
smooth smooth flow of the air so the
wing becomes much less efficient even if
the shape hasn't changed that much all
right let's look at the kinds of clouds
you've got basically the the prefix to
the cloud tells you what height it is
and then the second part of the word
tells you kind of the shape of the cloud
so I'll just let you absorb this a
little bit if it says Nimbo or NIM you
know
cumulonimbus or nimbostratus that means
it's raining towering cumulus is bad if
they talk about that and cumulonimbus is
the worst that's just another fancier
way of saying thunderstorm okay
so here's your Latin lesson for today
unfortunately I didn't study Latin it
would have been nice when I went to Peru
to be able to communicate with the
locals in Latin America okay that wasn't
funny I guess if you have low clouds the
main hazard to worry about is icing if
the water is supercooled that's the
worst you can usually get a forecast of
that you'll get air mats for icing and
they might talk about supercooled water
as a hazard I guess this might be an
exam question stratus clouds form when
moist stable air flows upslope but just
remember stable usually means flat
clouds stratiform clouds and unstable is
where you get the cumuliform clouds
so same deal
those altocumulus are going to be much
more turbulent and probably a more
severe icing potential the high clouds
it's so cold in the high atmosphere that
the maximum amount of water that can be
stored is pretty low and therefore you
don't tend to get ice when it's below
say minus 15 degrees Celsius there just
isn't a whole lot of moisture to begin
with okay so this is what as a GA pilot
you're more likely to have to worry
about you're probably not going to be up
at 25,000 feet and your piper warrior
but you could be underneath a cumulus
cloud I will tell you that if you have
passengers and there's low cumulus
clouds you desperately want to get above
those so let's say there's a bunch of
cumulus clouds at four or five thousand
feet you can climb probably to eight or
ten thousand feet in a light airplane
and it'll be much much smoother so as
soon as you get above the cumulus clouds
that's where the air tends to smooth out
and it will be much more comfortable but
if it's a towering cumulus cloud they
may go up to as high as sixty thousand
feet in the down in Texas and you really
can't get over them and anything short
of an sr-71 or maybe last as f-22 even
the latest Gulf Stream flown to go to
51,000 I believe
okay so thunderstorms are the worst
hazard you know even airliners get in
trouble and thunderstorms with hail
smashing into the windshield and
turbulence that can bend stuff so how do
you predict if you're flying along
and well if you're preparing to go on a
flight how do you predict where the
clouds are likely to be one thing you do
is look at the temperature dew point and
spread the FAA tells you to use a lapse
rate of 2.5 degrees Celsius to figure
out where the clouds will be so if
there's a 10 degree temperature dew
point spread then you should expect the
clouds to have a base at about 4,000
feet there's a typo on the slide sorry
about that I thought we had the new
version in the drop box the temperature
lapse is at 2:00 at 3:00 and the dupe
for the dry adiabatic air you remember
that and the dew points at 0.5 so if we
go back to that figure I think it was
hour yeah yeah if we go back here you
remember this we went from 18 to 15 to
12 and the dew point meanwhile is
falling from 3 to 2 and a half to 2 so
that's why it's 2.5 as a rule of thumb
that's not great but you can actually if
you study just just look at me tars
around the country and I think you'll
will see because they give you the bases
of the clouds and the ceilings I think
you usually will see that it's
reasonably close to this formula
but almost never spot-on okay this is
this is worth studying I'm not going to
cover it completely here but some of
these are exam questions advection fog I
think I remember they like to ask about
that when the warm moist air moves over
a cool surface along coastlines so I
think that'd make sense maybe that's
what they're having in California a lot
of the time you know they have the fog
over the coastal areas
I think and radiation fog also like you
know in the Western deserts oftentimes
right there's fog in the morning so I
think the air advection fog would be a
coastal phenomenon and the radiation fog
you know something they could have in
you know place like Arizona or Palm
Springs okay
the sa he loves this if you see I see I
see pellets you probably shouldn't be
flying but they want you to know that if
you do see ice pellets how did they
arrive well they had to be freezing rain
up higher so don't climb in hopes of
getting out of the ice pellets because
then you'll have freezing rain on your
airplane which is probably the worst
kind of icing related hazard okay air
masses you can just have a look here
basically they're just if you hear that
you know there's a polar air mass coming
in it's going to be cold not too
exciting might be a question fronts they
do want you to see be able to read one
of these maps they may occasionally ask
you a question so one thing to remember
is the cold front has the pointy spikes
like icicles so if you can remember that
you'll be pretty good there's a cold
front again you can
just kind of read this and study it at
your leisure
I guess they might want you to remember
that the front is the boundary between
two air masses okay here's a typical
drawing that you know where they'll show
you the cold fronts and the warm fronts
when there is a front how do you know
when the front has gone through well the
temperature has changed and the wind has
changed simple as that
here's a little explanation of what you
can expect when a cold front goes
through
everybody's happy with that okay when a
warm front goes through it gets warmer
afterwards yeah so the warm front
produces as you can see you know light
to moderate rain drizzle the visibility
is bad that's actually the important
thing here look at the visibility it's
poor and then it becomes fair and haze
whereas you know the visibility becomes
really good after a cold front comes
through occluded fronts
same deal bad visibility alright let's
talk about hazards this is kind of more
important so this is a summary of where
heat is released into the atmosphere
versus absorbed by water so as the water
goes for example from vapor to liquid it
releases heat so that's exactly what's
happening when it's raining in a
thunderstorm and it's not a good thing
all right so here's the FAS chart of a
cumulus cloud forming so you can see the
temp of the lapse rate over here in the
ambient atmosphere it's going from 28 to
24 and down to 21 so it is at least
initially higher than standard lapse
rate so this warm air it starts at 28
and then it drops only to 25 so it's
still warmer than the surrounding air so
it goes into becoming this big nasty
cloud there's this
you can kind of see if you don't want to
look at the summaries of weather
forecasts you can look at these charts
of lifted index here it shows the
difference between minus 18 and minus 11
of minus 7 that gives you kind of a
measure of the thunderstorm potential
there are charts of that but as pilots
you know this is kind of more what we
deal with on our practical day-to-day
basis we just look at the next rad data
from the radar stations that are strewn
around the country and if it's red we
try to find a path around it because
there's just not much else you can do
and a little aircraft you know it's
possible that you could get over this
entire front if you you know we're in a
jet that could climb up to 40 thousand
feet or higher but you know in a piper
or a Cessna or a cirrus you're just not
going to be able to do that ok the
thunderstorm lifecycle this is I think a
favorite test question how do you know
that the thunderstorm has reached its
mature stage well it's rainy simple as
that if it's raining it's mature if it's
dissipating you're gonna get these down
drafts if it's building you get updrafts
so everything comes up and then it all
comes down ok
look at that nasty thunderstorm you're
gonna get turbulence right on top of it
if you can clear that thunderstorm by
you know 5,000 feet it'll probably be
nice and smooth so this is your good
argument for a plane that can go 251
flight level 5 on zero airliners don't
go that high as oh wait it's this Jets
go much higher than airliners
alright the Hazzard your we're gonna
hear more about this tomorrow from dojo
from the Brazilian Air Force but there
is this chart here that shows you how
much load factor that's in G's if you're
going pretty fast you can pretty quickly
get into the structural damage range so
that's why they tell you this these
lines here are basically this is how
many G's you can get on the aircraft
with either extreme movements on the
controls or extreme movements that are
imposed on you by a thunderstorm or
something so the takeaway from this
diagram is slow down if you get into
heavy turbulence because then the
airplane will stall before it bends and
installing the stalling can be corrected
by pushing the nose down okay so these
are all the hazards from thunderstorms
again it's it's a lot better in this in
this day and age there's so much
information out there and data link
available in the cockpit that going
through thunderstorms is just much less
common than it used to be and therefore
you know you don't really have to
remember too much other than don't fly
through a thunderstorm microburst
however if you're trying to land and
beat the thunderstorm you can actually
get into a little bit of trouble because
the wind right before a thunderstorm or
right after can be pretty squirrelly and
caused you some difficulties here
let's see what do we have so here this
airplane is giving a performance boost
from a strong headwind now it's not much
as happening except that it's getting
pushed down maybe faster than the
airplane can climb and at this point
you're getting a performance reduction
from this big tailwind so that's
reducing you might think well that's
great I'm getting pushed along with a
tailwind but if it's suddenly taking
away your airspeed then that's not a
performance boost all right so the
thunderstorm emergency procedures are
again probably a little bit less
relevant now that we're living in this
world of constant data link and NEXRAD
data 2006 there was a famous accident
with a former test pilot Scott
Crossfield who you know maybe didn't get
the best advice from air traffic control
and I don't think he had data link in
his cockpit the Boeing b-29 bomber crews
they would fly I think seven or eight
hours from an island to in the Pacific
over to Japan and during those eight
hours they had you know satellite data
no data from a ground station so they
just had no idea what they were going
through and they didn't go as high as
the designers thought that airplane was
designed to go super high but they were
so loaded up with fuel and bombs they
couldn't practically climb all that high
so they were going at you know ten
fifteen thousand feet over the ocean and
at those altitudes you can't really see
you know you may get into an embedded
thunderstorm today's airliners they go
so high that you really are never in a
position where you blunder into stuff or
almost never because you're in the clear
and you can just see the towering
cumulus and not fly there use factor
yourself around them so I guess yeah the
final statement there is you know get
their itis hasn't been cured so as a
pilot the safest thing you can do is
really fight that tendency to want to
complete
a mission as planned and over commit to
your plan of action all right there are
three other categories of turbulence to
worry about probably the worst is from
[Music]
due to terrain like mountains this
low-level turbulence is not from
thermals is not crazy but as I said if
you get above the clouds that plane on
top is gonna be a nice smooth air weight
turbulence at us is also another thing
to consider let's look at that so if
you're if you're taking off behind an
airplane so look at that heavy slow and
in clean configuration so airplanes will
tend to retract their flaps and
therefore be in a clean configuration
shortly after takeoff whereas if they're
landing the flaps are down they're not
generating quite as much wake turbulence
although still if you land behind a
Boeing in your little Cessna you will
notice that the solution here and I
think this is a test question is you
land or take off beyond the touchdown
point of a large aircraft so if the
large aircraft let's say the large
aircraft landed right here in front of
the laptop on the runway you just fly a
little bit higher and you land you know
maybe in the middle of the runway and
that way you can't possibly get into
wake turbulence because it will have
sunk below that big aircraft's flight
path controllers at a towered Airport
they'll also separate you buy you know
the necessary number of minutes they
have a bunch of regulations about how
how much separation they have to have
between aircraft and then similarly for
liftoff point so if the big airplane
again this is not really that much of a
practical problem because it's so little
runway is used by light airplanes but if
the big airplane you know rotated and
took off and started climbing here well
then you take off and start climbing
earlier of course you know the out of
the climb rate of the big airplane is
probably a lot better than you are so
you got to think about which way the
wind is going and maybe try to to turn
away from it I I've only really been
stuck in wake turbulence once that I can
think about it was at Hanscom field and
there was a heavy helicopter that was
cleared oh man on the runway and then
transition sideways and I was in the
Cirrus and I think the controllers
didn't really think about you know well
how much weight turbine was gonna
helicopter generate so I was trying to
land and maybe about 200 feet above the
ground there was a sharp wing tip that I
the good the good news is you don't have
to be heroic to correct it because if
your airplane is banked the natural
tendency is to want to take the bank out
so whenever your natural tendency is to
do the safe thing that's usually not
much of a problem oh yeah
so anyway here's the kind of essay
question who wants to give an answer
shout it out a B or C
yay alright so this is a practical issue
especially for anybody who wants to fly
out west you have the Sierra Mountains
you have the Rocky Mountains and you
have to be very careful when crossing
these mountain ranges if the air at the
winds oh if the wind aloft forecast is
more than about 30 knots for the time
that you're planning on crossing you can
expect this kind of turbulence on the
lee side or the eastern side of those
mountain ranges so when I've crossed
those mountains and light airplanes
I have usually done it you know first
thing in the morning basically so I
arranged to shut down just short of the
mountains the night before and then
cross early in the morning when the
winds are typically calm so you know you
can look for these lenticular cloud
clouds but again if you saw the winds
aloft forecast that it was going to be
blowing 50 knots at 12,000 feet you can
be pretty sure that it's going to be
turbulent alright structural icing you
can get rime clear or mixed I'll just
let you kind of look through the
conditions that lead to this
queer and rhyme probably rhyme icing is
more common what happens everything gets
worse about your aircraft especially if
you're on autopilot it's kind of a
challenge to recognize when icing is
occurring you can be you know in there
fat dumb and happy all the airplane gets
iced up so the worst part of it I guess
is that you can't climb basically when
your airplane has all this performance
reduction you know you can summarize
this all if it's moderate if it's only
moderate icing basically you have an
aircraft that can't climb all you can do
is to send so a good practical tip is if
you're well first of all if you're a via
the good news is if you're a VFR pilot
like you guys are going to become
initially you shouldn't have to worry
about icing because it's a phenomenon
that occurs when you're in a cloud so
you shouldn't be in a cloud if you're a
VFR pilot to begin with so how did you
get ice the exception might be freezing
rain if you somehow drive through a
freezing rain but if you are
instrument-rated and you are going
somewhere I'm planning on going to New
York next week in the cirrus so if it's
cloudy even if there's no icing forecast
I can I know that there's a risk of
getting ice on the wings so in the
winter time I just say well look I'm not
gonna go unless it's above freezing on
the surface because if I get iced up
then inadvertently you know I need an
escape route and if it's gonna be above
freezing that say 3,000 feet well that's
fine I'll just I know that I probably
won't be able to climb if I if I get
moderate icing but I will be able to
descend you can even a brick can descend
so to send down to 3,000 feet and all
the ice will melt off that would be
great but if it's below freezing on the
surface and it's a it's basically you
know I know guys I definitely had icing
a few times and it's pretty scary I was
on a day out on a day when with a
instrument student and it was it seemed
like a perfect day to go practice
instrument flying there was no
turbulence there was just clouds
everywhere about 800 feet of ceiling so
you could be in the clouds do real
approaches get experience with actual
IMC and halfway through the flight I
started you know criticizing this guy
for using way too much power like the
power settings were all off like wow you
know what are you doing wrong and then I
kind of looked out on the wings and I
saw they were all frosted so we
descended we managed to complete an ILS
approach into Lawrence and pulled the
airplane into a warm hangar and got it
warmed up so actually as we were as we
were flying the FAA issued an air met
for icing but the controller's never
told us about it all right requirements
for icing formation near freezing
temperatures minus ten to zero is the
worst you have to have a surface on
which the ice can form and you have to
be invisible Moisture basically so again
if you're flying in the clear with your
VFR pilot certificate icing should not
be a factor for you yeah so as I said
below you know go through a cold cloud
only if you have an escape route warm
air below
[Music]
[Applause]
sure dear
yes so the question is what about icing
and the engine so you can get car bites
that we talked about you know you can
get car bites when it's you know 50
degrees outside as long as it's humid so
it's slightly unrelated the main problem
with engines is that you can get ice in
the induction so if the intake for the
engine where it's trying to breathe gets
iced over then there's an alternate air
again you know they're kind of relying
on the hero pilot some airplanes
actually it'll just open automatically
that the vacuum of trying to suck the
air through the intake that's not
working will cause some backup door to
open and a lot of most IFR certified air
aircraft have an alternate air levered
that you can pull and have air pulled
from you know somewhere inside the it's
a little more protected inside the
airframe that does that answer your
question
as long as which he
you're not gonna get carb icing an
airframe icing at the same time probably
I think at that point it's probably too
cold I'm not I'm not sure well the other
issue is you know you're probably not
gonna fly a carbureted airplane into the
clouds because like the Rio IFR
airplanes that people use to travel like
syriza's and bonanzas and stuff you know
in in in challenging conditions those
are almost all fuel-injected but you do
have to worry about induction icing like
I said okay you can icing layers are
usually pretty thin so if you're in a
jet you just add power and climb up
another few thousand feet and you're out
of it again you know one of the effects
of icing is to dramatically reduce your
climb performance so this this best
approach of climbing out of it is not
always available you will end up using
more power on the final approach and
you'll add speed as well because the
stall speed may have gone up and you
know you you can't really be sure since
it hasn't been you know quantified and
tested you probably won't use flaps and
you'll not make severe turn so there's a
good NASA video that I encourage you to
watch especially as you work on higher
performance aircraft and IFR nASA has
this great video about icing okay
how do the Transportation class
airplanes handle this one approach is to
push antifreeze out onto the wings that
used to be called tks now it's called CA
V it's just a brand name so if you go to
a flight school and you see a modern
service like the sr22 s the leading
edges of the wings will be metal and
they'll have little tiny holes in them
and that's for this antifreeze to come
out if you have a very light jet or a
turboprop you may have rubber boots on
the wings and on the tail surfaces and
those inflate to crack the ice off
the Jets are really the ultimate the the
bigger Jets
I'll have bleed air remember the Jets
are compressing air so much that it
becomes really hot even before it's
burned so you pull the bleed air off the
compressor and you run it out into the
leading edges of the wings and that just
melts the ice off the you know transport
air air aircraft
they also heat the windshields so you'll
be able to see when you do you know if
it's not above freezing at the airport
he'll have a clear windshield so you can
see the runway even in you know very
basic airplanes like a cirrus if there
are far certified the pitot the pitot
tube is going to be heated there will be
pitot heat okay
you can learn a whole bunch more about
this I think everything you know to pass
the test is pretty much in the pilots
handbook of aeronautical knowledge
there's a little bit in the aim if you
want to dig deeper and understand more
of it and I would encourage you to look
at these FAA
weather publications one is about
weather theory and one is about you know
information you can get from various
sources there's also these videos that I
would encourage you to look at one of
them is called you know ambushed by ice
and into deep
I think these particular links don't
write those down because I fixed them
last night but the Dropbox didn't update
it do they have real-time weather data
so the question is you know in your
basic trainer airplane do they have
real-time weather data so I'll just talk
about like the East Coast Aero Club is
sort of a typical higher-end flight
school about maybe 10 years ago almost
all the aircraft had a Garmin IFR
certified GPS put in a Garmin 4:30 so at
that point you know you had a really
good GPS but they did not have XM
weather pulling data from satellites
which we'll talk about in a little bit
because it's a it's a you know it's like
a $500 year subscription to $10,000 box
so people didn't want to do it with ABS
be the FAA is now providing some of the
same data that XM was providing for free
as long as you have an ATS be in
transponder and the East Coast air out
well everybody has to upgrade to a DSP
by 2020 not everybody has to have a DSP
in but I think East Coast era clubs
probably a fairly typical of the better
flight schools they put or they're
gradually putting in ABS be in and out
transponders and all their aircraft it
won't display in the cockpit you'll have
to have your phone your iPad or
something but you'll be able to see
you'll be able to see an X rad radar
picture you'll be able to get me tars
and taps you'll get all of that so I
think but if you don't want to rely on
someone else you know where this is MIT
you can actually get that data yourself
so when we talk about weather data today
we're gonna also talk about how you can
build it do it yourself
build your own Stratus a DSP receiver
and so you and I've actually done this
it was really fun to do it's very easy
actually it's you basically based on a
Raspberry Pi with a couple antennas you
can with a little cooling fan you can
build a little box that can receive that
weather data and it actually this the
software is open source and it can sync
with your other tools so I have it sync
with my for flight app so when I'm
flying I plug that in I bring a backup
battery for it and it gives me weather
data and some other traffic data and
we'll be talking about that in a couple
hours
yeah I should have noticed as seen this
had a lot of flight school customers you
know for the last five years would bring
little battery-powered boxes and you
know stick them to the windshield of
whatever they're flying and they would
get a whole bunch of you know more
modern services I personally don't love
that you know like when I started out in
my flying career I had my big flight bag
with all the stuff I was going to bring
into the airplane and now you know I
have the philosophy that I don't want to
bring anything into the Cirrus other
than a pencil I wanted
that I need to to be in the panel so but
yeah I definitely think in the older
airplanes it's become conventional for
people to bring some sort of 80s be a
receiver and get that data
you